[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau 78 weekend pendant 26
minutes nous allons revenir he sur les
moments forts de l'actualité culture
loisirs et sport de la semaine au cours
de cette émission je recevrai Sylvie
laouna la directrice divine tourisme qui
vous donnera les prochaines idées de
sortie pour l'auton à ne pas rater mais
tout d'abord place à l'événement
culturel du weekend je veux bien sûr
parler des 20 ans de Déclic Théâtre pour
pour rappel c'est évidemment la
compagnie qui a lancé Jamel de bous ou
encore sopia Haram et bien dans kiosque
cette semaine Aurélia debissi a consacré
une émission spéciale à la compagnie
trapiste la compagnie a été créée en
1993 sous l'impulsion de Alain Degois d
papi et Jean-Baptiste Chauvin donc qui
étaient tous les deux cofondateurs de la
compagnie euh mais on peut dire que déqu
théâtre ça existait déjà avant
puisqueeffectivement papi découvre
l'improvisation théâtrale le match
d'improvisation théâtrale dans le milieu
des années 80 sur Saint-Quentin en
Yveline avec le Théâtre de l'Unité et et
dès le milier des années 80 il développe
des projets en milieu scolaire alors il
était à l'époque éducateur voilà et puis
puis aussi par la suite il a travaillé à
la maérie de trap il développe des
projets avec la CT la merurise euh et
puis puis en réaction à un moment parce
que les projets ne peuvent pas se
poursuivre il décide de créer la
compagnie des clics théâtrre pour
poursuivre les projets notamment en
milieu scolaire et puis pour pour créer
une compagnie quels sont les les
qualités les bonnes qualités qui qu'il
faut avoir pour être un improvisateur
alors en fait j'ai demandé j'ai demandé
à chona tout à l'heure parce que je
savais pas trop moi-même et elle m'a dit
il faut avoir de l'imagination donc ça
c'est quand même assez important
l'imagination pour toiimagination c'est
c'est une grande partie euh de l'impro
surtout d'accord est-ce qu'il il y a
d'autres choses d'autres clés qui sont
qui sont important de je pense qu'il a
quelque chose qui est assez important
c'est d'avoir une assez vaste culture
générale mais pas forcément une culture
générale littéraire ou au sens strict du
terme faut pas forcément connaître tous
les auteurs classiques de théâtre et
cetera mais oui être ouvert à à ce qui
se passe dans dans le monde quoi
connaître un petit peu avoir des
références et ça aide beaucoup en fait
finalement pour avoir des espèces
d'images mentales de différentes
possibilités de situation parce qu'il
faut se représenter effectivement
mentalement les choses pour pouvoir les
les ner ex je vous demande de me faire
une improvisation à la manère de la
science-fiction Aelia h je non voilà
parce que vous ne regardez pas de film
de scifiction si pourtant si mais il y
en a tellement que je ne sais pas vers
lequ c'est un peu ça que d'avoir
suffisamment de références culturelles
pour pouvoir s'adapt à différents types
de jeux possibles et ça permet d'être à
l'aise dans le jeu après effectivement
faut avoir aussi de l'imagination il
faut être à l'écoute des autres
ouverture d'esprit ah mon Dieu non mais
c'est bon ça
vauc mieux pas regarder voilà s'il vous
plaît pouvez enlever cette
cette non je savais que c'était pas très
gentil de votre parents on avait dit pas
les vieilles images dit équité à chacun
on essaie de retrouver des Archiv était
beau à l'époque mais Géraldine on en a
pas d'image d'archives alors on a
retrouvé cette image Géraldine quand tu
avais 12 ans tu sortais de chez le
dentiste avec tes bagues comment es-tu
au courant e oui tu vois on sait tout
alors l'improvisation donc thatral c'est
un moyen de s'exprimer on l'a dit par le
langage par le MIM également donc en
fonction des des ressources imaginaires
que que l'on peut avoir donc certains
comme Jamel Debou sopia Haram Arnaud
samère Isa dondia pour ne citer que
voilà ont fait leur premier pas dans la
patinoire de Déclic Théâtre et sont
devenus des comédiens professionnels
reconnus du grand public alors on va
écouter justement Issa dumbia et Jamel
de Bou que l'on a rencontré plusieurs
fois mais là en l'occurrence il nous
explique en quoi l'impro leur apporté
des clés dans leur parcours
professionnel aujourd'hui je me base
beaucoup sur des textes mais quand il y
a certains certains réalisateurs qui qui
nous disent bah si tu as de nouvelles
proposition pour ton personnage vas-y
bah c'est une source de proposition
l'improvisation théâtrale puisque j'ai
fait des films où j'ai improvisé des
scènes qui sont restées à l'image donc
du coup quand on les voit au cinéma on
se dit que c'est écrit mais en fait ça
vient de l'improvisation et bah c'est
pour ça que Déclic Théâtre m'a beaucoup
beaucoup apporté j'y suis toujours la
compagne
je suis là la preuve à chaque événement
j'essaie d'être présent écoutez monsieur
l'arbitre apparemment vous l'avez pas
changé aussi énervé pour
rien j'ai pensé que ça pourrait amuser
le
public BR en
ridicule merci
capitaine
la leçon que j'ai retenu l'écoute j'
dire exactement la même chose donc on
est sur la même
longueur c'est l'écoute la valeur
principale écouter l'autre pour pouvoir
créer avec lui sinon c'est pas
possible noublie pas ça mais ça me sert
encore aujourd'hui quandand je tour AC
Fernando il y a pas
longtemps et je te jure que c'est ces
outils comm filé en impro qui me servent
encore
aujourd'hui quand je ne sais pas
j'écoute et et
bizarrement bizarrement je je je finis
par
savoir et si vous voulez vous aussi ins
souffler les bougies de la compagnie des
clic théâtrre rendez-vous ce samedi 12
octobre à partir de 20h30 à la meurise
att trrape cette semaine Montini le
broteneux organise la 10e Semaine
justement de du handicap et une
compétition y est de plus en plus
populaire il s'agit de la course
interentreprise les équipes engagées
permettent de récolter des fonds pour
une association d'enfants handicapés
Olivier Manis calco et Elodie moine vêtu
d'un t-shirt rouge et sourir aux lèvres
les enfants handicapés de l'IME des
ménul sont déjà à l'échauffement dans
quelques instants ils prendront le
départ de la 5e course interentreprise
de Montini ça fait la 3e année ou 4e
année consécutive qu'on participe à
cette course et je trouve ça bien pour
les jeunes parce que courir on s'occupe
que de soi et on va le plus loin
possible plus vite possible c'est parti
s c'est les premiers mais pas tous lu
deè course mais lui je l'ai à l'il que
je perde dans les
r organisé par l'association spéciale
olympique France le principe de cette
course est simple les entreprises
inscrivent leurs équipes de qu coureurs
qui s LAN pour 10 km sous forme de
relais l'inscription coûte 800 € par
équipe et les fonds récoltés sont revers
aux enfants handicapés j'aijà fait
semiathon pour les handicapés ch voilose
précis c'est très convivial en plus on
se retrouve avec plusieurs entreprises
et voilà donc c'est la fête donc
profitons-en les relayeurs débutent de
la place Étienne Marcel pour un effort
de 2 km demi croisant régulièrement les
enfants pour qui il court chacun fait de
son mieux même si le sport n'est pas
forcément une sinécure pour certains cé
pour la bonne cause donc voilà on a tout
donné et au final on a fait un bon temps
en plus on les a vu devant nous qui
courit donc voilà le fond nous faut
qu'on le fasse encore à 400 % 77 équipes
pour 310 coureurs ont participé à la
course cette année 43200 € ont pu être
récolté c'est 8000 € de mieux que
l'année
dernière et comme tous les 15 jours
désormais Sylvie laouna nous rend visite
la directrice divlin tourisme bonjour à
vous bonjour alors des idées de sorties
pour l'automne cette fois-ci je crois
qu'on va commencer peut-être par la la
cuueillette des pomme c'est peut-être un
petit peu la saison aussi non c'est ça
c'est la saison et c'est le le moment où
il faut les cueillir et comme ça on en a
pour tout les versions les garde au
frais il y a plusieurs variétés qu'on
peut découvrir non seulement à la ferme
de Gal à saint-cirlécole mais aussi à la
ferme de jumoville La Ferme du logis et
là on découvre toutes les variétés de
pommes on est au grand TER on les
cuueille c'est c'est super agréable il
ne fait pas trop froid aussi du côté de
Versailles pour faire du vélo aux
alentours de la ville il y a des
nouveaux circuits qui ont été mis en
place à versaill dans le cadre de
l'Année lonau des circuits culture
nature donc on peut découvrir trois
types de de circuits un très sportif on
passe par la forêt il y a 20 km donc il
faut quand même être un petit peu
entraîné et puis deux autres circuits
euh qui sont faits pour découvrir tout
l'aspect culturel et les quartiers de
Versailles le quartier Saint-Louis les
deux quartiers historiques Saint-Louis
Notre-Dame puis la nouvelle cour des
centeurs et le musée Lambinet donc on
passe par tous ces points-là avec son
vélo ou alors on peut découvrir à
travers les grandes avenues euh la
belleeville de Versailles et puis c'est
le c'est le moment quand on prend les
grandes avenues parce que c'est facile
avec les pistes cycllbles d'être en
famille et si on n pas de vélo pour
parcourir Versailles on peut en avoir un
en et bien on vous en prête donc il y a
même pas de prétexte pour dire on ne
peut pas faire on peut on peut en faire
même si on n' pas de vélo absolument cet
automne les inois vont pouvoir découvrir
ou redécouvrir pour ceux qui qui la
connaissent déjà la forêt de
Saint-Germain en lait aussi oui parce
que l'Office de Tourisme de
Saint-Germain en lait nous a concocté le
mini guide nature donc de la forêt de
Saint et du domaine national dans ce
mini guide il y a tout un tas de choses
pour préserver la la biodiversité pour
découvrir les champignons ne pas se
tromper prendre des bons champignons
parce que ça aussi c'est la la
cueillette typique après les pommes
l'automne ce sont les champignons et
puis vous avez également la découverte
de la faune et de la flore bien sûr donc
ce petit guide est gratuit à l'ofice de
tourisme de Saint-Germain en et c'est le
moment de d'aller le chercher il y a une
date importante aussi du côté de du
domaine national de Rambouillet je crois
c'est le 20 octobre oui c'est le
dimanche de la chasse au vol avec les
rapasses donc on est avec les chasseurs
d'île-de-fance et on est dans dans le
l'espace de de de Rambouillet le domaine
national et dans un espace qui est fermé
habituellement au public et donc on peut
les accompagner dans leur chasse au vol
avec les rapaces on a un déjeuner tiré
du sac et on vit un moment
extraordinaire comme si on était
quelques siècles en arrière c'est vrai
que le vol d' rapace c'est toujours
quelque chose de d'ASS
euh toujours à rambouiller cette fois-ci
vous en parlez un petit peu tout à
l'heure la découverte de la mychologie
oui alors qu'est-ce que donc la
mycologie c'est la découverte des
champignons euh alors quel quel type de
de de champignon choisir on vous le dit
lors d'une sortie mycologie qui se
déroule encore une fois à Rambouillet et
donc on vous explique que parfois on
peut même découvrir quel est le bon
champignon et le et le distinguer du
mauvais grâce simplement à l'odorat en
le sentant euh on vous explique tout ça
quel est le bon quel est le mauvais on
découvre la nature on est dans un
environnement naturel exceptionnel c'est
le c'est le bon moment pour y aller puis
ça fait tellement plaisir à tout le
monde de de découvrir des nouveautés
donc le le ces deux ces deux sorties
sont sur le site de l'office de tourisme
de Rambouillet le nouveau site internet
n'hésitez pas euh on va changer un petit
peu de coin dans les evines on va aller
au pays des impressionnistes du côté de
Chatou notamment par là c'est ça voilà
avec un peu de culture là oui cette
fois-ci c'est la sortie Curel et c'est
le 19 octobre donc on est sur les rives
du PEC et là c'est vraiment la bonne
randonnée il faut bien se chausser après
le vélo cette fois-ci c'est à pied et
donc on va aller
vers donc sur cette balade automnale on
va découvrir les vignes derrière la
terrasse de de Saint-Germain et on va
rentrer par le le bois du vaisinet donc
encore des espaces naturels exceptionnel
donc c'est encore une fois nature
culture hein c'est on on a beau dire
notre département des ivelines il est
très fort pour tout ça et puis ça ça
montre encore une fois qu'il y a des
vignes dans les ivelines chose qui peut
être parfois surprenante pour les les
amateurs de vin il y a il y a les
vendanges il faut surtout pas c'est fait
comm comme celles qui ont été faites à a
encour ce weekend enfin ce samedi pe
peut-être l'endroit idéal j'ai envie de
dire pour les amateurs de plantes oui
parce que c'est le le marché aux fleurs
et aux plantes à poissie c'est là le 12
donc demain où on pourra choisir ces
différentes plantes les Dalias les
plantes qui vont être encore valables
jusqu'aux premières gelées les pensées
les Dalias ce genre de de fleurs et puis
les enfants il auront une occupation
parce que les parents vont vont faire
leurs achats pour leur balcon leur
jardin mais les enfants vont avoir des
des ateliers de jardinage donc ils sont
occupés pendant que les parents font
leur leurs emplettes voilà vous avez une
plante favorie peut-être chez vous
Sylvie non quelque chose qui vous plaît
particulièrement le Dalia je trouve que
le Dalia pompon là en en automne est
très joli on dirait on dirait une petite
sculpture avec plein plein de pétales je
le trouve très beau à recommander alors
peut-être pour les futursinois qui iront
du côté de ce samedi merci beaucoup
Sylvie d'être passé sur le setute
weekend et puis à bientôt pour de
nouvelles idées de sorties dans les
ivelines il n'y a pas que dans le
Bordelet on parlait d'ailleurs des
vignes il y a quelques minutes que la
vigne offre du bon vin aux amateurs à H
encour la tradition des vendanges vient
de fêter ses 20 ans déjà un âge de
maturité he d'ailleurs pour pour un bon
vin le cru 2013 va-t-il être bon élément
de réponse avec Catherine
zulato non vous n'êtes pas à la campagne
ni dans le bordelai ou en Bourgogne mais
dans le vieux village d'élancour
derrière la ferme du Mousseau là où sont
plantés 160 pieds de vigne du raisin
noir et du raisin blanc ici on avait des
beau pieds de Rais de raisin blanc et
donc un hybride qui est noté ici là
c'est du cvilard
5276 tous les ans l'association des Amis
du passé des lancours s'active avec les
enfants à perpétrer la trad i des
vendanges d'abord la taille de la vigne
les premiers pieds ont été plantés il y
a 22 ans sont bon
encore c'est une année moyenne si ce
n'est sur le mûissement mais on voit que
malgré le murissement qui n'est pas
complet et bien que à l'arrivée on
pourrait faire même je dirais du bon
champagne on a du raisin noir peut-être
qu' est pas mûri complètement mais quand
on goûte le jus de raisin ben c'est
inattendu c'està-dire malgré tout sucré
doit y avoir un peu de degré d'alcool
après la taille de la vigne opération
foulage à l'ancienne là ce sont les
petits pieds d'enfants qui offici pour
écraser des grains de raisin et il n'y a
pas d'âge impression mitigée en fait je
suis en train d'écraser le raisin mais
c'est hyper gelé c'est hyper froid bah
pour fabriquer du jus de raisin et du
vin c'est froid et puis c'est un peu
dégoûtant rassure-toi Emma tout est
prévu u est installé pour se nettoyer
les pieds une pause dégustation le
raisin sera ensuite grappé puis
pressé raisin cette année cette année
les vendanges devrai permettre de
produire une vingtaine de litres de jus
de raisin une trentaine de litres de vin
blanc et 12 l de rosé à consommer bien
entendu avec modération not jus de
pasteurisé jus de raisin d'accord on en
a fait une douzaine là on a un peu de
vin blanc et puis là on a les tonneau
c'est dans en TER battu et en pierre de
meulière que le précieux liquide est
conservé cette année les vendangé enc
fêtent leur 20
ans comme chaque semaine désormais nous
vous faisons découvrir le coup de cœur
des cinémas cinquantinois cette fois-ci
c'est Luc bean du ciné7 d'lencour qui
vous parle de mon âme partoi guéri mon
coup de cœur cette semaine c'est le
dernier film de François dupéron mon âme
partoi guéri donc le François duperon
que j'aime moi puisque je me souviens
d'avoir vu au cinéma la chambre des
officiers c'est quoi la vie avec
Daroussin notamment qui joue aussi dans
dans ce film donc c'est un très beau
film touchant profond délicat avec un
acteur don je vais lire le nom parce que
j'ai du mal à m'en souvenir à chaque
fois Grégory Gadebois qui a joué dans
Angel et Tony que j'avais vu il y a
quelques temps qui est un très très bon
acteur qui est sociétaire de la Comédie
[Musique]
Française
laissez-moi 5 minutes j'aitre un don
mare m'a transm don pas réveill les Mor
c'est l'histoire d'un d'un jeune homme
qui fait de la moto motard qui perd sa
mère qui lui a comment dirais-je légué
des des talent pardon de guérisseur donc
il va refuser ce talent il va rencontrer
une jeune femme qui est perdu comme lu
un peu dans la vie et il va s'apercevoir
qu'il faut qu'il utilise ce talent qu'il
refusait jusqu'à présent voilà je vous
en dis pas plus c'est vous qui es en
train de me
[Musique]
guérir et pour conclure ce 78 weekend
place au sport évidemment c'était le
premier derby d'une longue série dans
cette poule de National 3 en recevant
l'entente le chîn et versaill l'étoile
des chemineau de trappe avait l'occasion
d'affirmer hein sa suprématie sur le
département et ses ambitions pour a
monté en fin de saison de son côté le
LCV pouvait enchaîner par une 3ème
victoire consécutive récite ce match
avec Patrick Jacques de dixmud et
Olivier
Maniscalco comme un signe pour son
premier derby trapis sur le banc
versaillais romain dubauaronte son
ancien formateur mostafha et lafidi
c'est un match particulier ça fait 10
ans je crois qu'on a pas vu un derby
trappe versaill donc forcément ça a une
saveur particulière moi j'étais j'étais
gamin quand j'ai vu le derniers match de
trap versaill donc c'est un peu
particulier même pour moi on va démarrer
ce match là plein pot comme on sait le
faire et on va jouer notre chance
jusqu'au bout jusqu'au bout ils
tenteront de contrecarer la marche en
avant cinquantinoise notre équipe est
meilleure de semaine en semaine c'est
une équipe toute jeune en âge mais
également en cohésion puisque ils se
connaissent depuis un mois hein et donc
cette cohésion est en train de se
construire largement dominé dans les air
les Versaillais mettent comme prévu
beaucoup de rythmes dès les premières
minutes de jeu pour surprendre la
défense cquantinoise et avec 15 fautes
d'équipe au cours de la première période
l'indiscipline trapis coûte cher après
avoir eu 6 points de retard les
Versaillais basculent logiquement tête à
la pause
35-33 face au jeu très offensif des
visiteurs les trapis répondent par une
belle adresse extérieure et un festival
de d de Dialo Mamery en fin de match les
jeunes joueurs cinquentinois prouvent
leur maîtrise devant l'expérience
versaillaise les trapises font la loi au
rebond et toujours aussi à droit au
shoot il creusent l'écart pour
finalement s'imposer 80 69 la marche
était un peu haute pour le LCV face à
une équipe taillée pour la Nationale 2
on savait que c'était un derby il
fallait
assurer et puis on a fait ce qu'il
fallait on a on a on a appliqué les
conss du coach et puis ça a payé et pour
le compte de la 5e journée ce weekend
Trapp se déplace à malakov dans les
hautes scènes et l'entente le chaîn et
Versailles receverra le ministère des
Finances après deux montées consécutives
les féminines de l'Entente voisin
saint-arnou cette fois-ci s'affirment en
National 2 c'est du tennis de table pour
leur seconde saison au haut niveau
dernière preuve en date leur écrasante
victoire aroues le weekend dernier 8-0
elles ont désormais l'étiquette de
favorite il faut le dire pour la
nationale une nous avons voulu voir
comment elle vivait ce nouveau statut il
est fini le temps où les joueuses de
l'Entente voisin saint-arnou étaiai un
peu comme le cadeau surprise au pied du
sapin le soir de Noël on ne sait pas ce
qu'il contient mais la réponse est
souvent éclatante et pour leur seconde
année en National 2 les bicinoises
doivent assumer leur nouveau statut
c'est compliqué à gérer parce qu'on est
l'équipe à battre donc on sait très bien
que toutes les équipes vont renforcer
sur nous vont essayer de jouer leur max
sur nous celle qui veut monter alors que
l'année dernière elles avaient moins
peur de nous puisque on était la petite
équipe une petite équipe qui a bien
grandi malgré un premier match gagné
dans la douleur face à Saint-Denis les
cinquantinoises montrent déjà leur
progrès au haut niveau il nous fallait
cette victoire pour lancer la la pooule
je pense que maintenant les filles elles
sont lancées il faut se rappeler aussi
que l'année dernière on avait commencé
la pooule avec une défaite l'année
dernière sur Poitier en N2 pareil même
match match très compliqué les filles
pas dedans et et en fin de compte
derrière on arrive devant Poitier et on
loupe la monté au début quoi à
l'intersaison seu la jeune Sarah Bonali
est venue renforcer l'équipe les
vcinoises en ont profité pour partir en
stage à margevol dans le langd ça permet
déjà de reprendre l'entraînement et en
plus de souder alors c'est pour nous
c'est aussi valable pour les plus jeunes
ça Perm vraent un groupe de partir tous
ensemble à l'extérieur sans les
parentsans problèm et c'est s grâce à
cette cohésion
queamillec parcours scolaire à rigné à
voisin cet été c'est un peu compliqué
parce que j'ai les études en plus et
donc làah j'ai un peu moins en tête le
pingpong mais pour l'équipe je reste et
donc je m'entraîne le plus possible les
ivelinoises ne cachent pas leurs
ambitions derrière leur raquettes en
phase une ou en phase 2 la montée en
National une reste l'objectif
prioritaire vous le savez l'équipe de
France se prépare actuellement à Claire
Fontaine dans les Yvelines pour la dou
de confrontation he face à l'Australie
ce vendredi en amical et mardi prochain
pour le dernier match de qualification
face à la Finlande et cette semaine le
Parisien Blaise matudi a retrouvé un
ancien coéquipier en la personne de
Mamadou Sako désormais joueur de
Liverpool en Angleterre le défenseur
central formé au parisaingermain s'est
exilé outre Manche pour retrouver du
temps de jeu et couper le cordon avec le
PSG qui qui dont le son entraînement est
à Saint-Germain en lait il a également
mentionner le niveau de la première
ligue anglaise cette semaine en
conférence de presse on l'écoute c'est
un très gros changement pour moi moi moi
qui qui suis natif de Paris qui est vécu
dans dans dans différents
arrondissements de la capitale j'ai
jamais bougé comme je dis pour moi pour
moi j'ai j'ai j'ai pris mon mon
indépendance c'est comme si je vivais
chez mes parents et et j'ai et là je
viens de prendre mon appartement tout
seul entre guillemets parce que voilà
changer de pays changer de de de culture
une nouvelle langue une nouvelle façon
de vivre c'est sûr pour moi ça ça change
beaucoup mais mais je m'y fais très bien
et et c'est un style de vie qui me plaît
énormément et l'ancien Parisien mamadous
Sako va retrouver la pelouse du Parc des
Princes ce soir face à l'Australie
justement mais a priori il ne serait pas
titulaire et laisserait sa place à Eric
Abidal et Raphaël Varane en défense
centrale pour terminer ce 78 weekend
place à l'agenda V rendez-vous culturel
et sportif pour votre weekend j'enarlait
en début d'émission la compagnie des
clic théâtre fait ses 20 ans ce weekend
rendez-vous à à la Merise àrappe à
partir de 20h30 pour voir les comédiens
vous pourrez découvrir également ce
weekend des groupes de musique au
festival food rock à staminés c'est à à
maninamo seven weeks Bukovski ou encore
novels donneront des concerts jusqu'à
samedi soir plus d'informations sur
www.foodrck.fr et enfin en sport vous
pourrez aller supporter les chocs
deslancours pour leur premier match à
domicile en National 2 au gymnase
Chastanier ce samedi soir face à rouan
coup d'envoi à 20h évidemment à en cours
et enfin dans kusk petit rappel de vos
émissions la semaine prochaine kusk donc
votre émission culture Aurélia debici
vous parlera du danse Trophy avec la
grande chorégraphe miia Fray c'est un
concours de danse nationale qui fait
étape à plaisir à partir de mercredi
prochain ou des groupe de danse de salon
ou de danse contemporaine vont
s'affronter pour obtenir leurs tickets
pour la finale début novembre à Bordeaux
et puis pour ma part je vous retrouverz
dans le 78 sport avec Yan ku désormais
partisan du et surtout faisant part du
top 30 monde de tennis fauteuil le
joueur rambolitin qui vise évidemment
toujours les gios de Rio 2016 merci
beaucoup encore une fois d'avoir suivi
ce C weekend qui qui touche à sa fin bon
weekend et à la semaine
[Musique]
prochaine